When you know that
1 time we have set foot on European soil,
well,
we will be regularized where we will stay.
I was listening to Mrs.
Ayet when she said,
uh,
we'll see in 15 days if they are,
we will see in 15 days if we keep them or not.
Uh, Mrs. Ayet,
you know like me the
border rate?
It is also not 10% in France.
That is,
how are you going to evict these
tens of thousands more people?
The only way to block them,
the only one? Oh yes,
because the immigration pack will
change the laws in France and will allow
to override the decisions of the European Court of
justice. That, no,
is the only solution,
the only solution,
this is what Marine Le Pen and Jordan Bardella propose,
it is indeed 1,
1 real man referent on uh.
Immigration,
with uh.
1 series of measurements that allow
effectively render,
among others,
these effective evictions.
Today,
because of European law in particular,
we can't do it.